in march 2020 lucy esparza casarez got
sick
she quickly recovered from the headache
and chills but soon her husband david
was feeling very ill coughing and unable
to stand he was rushed to a hospital
lucy was not allowed to see her husband
and soon a nurse called to say david was
being put on a ventilator she said okay
so uh we were ready to do the procedure
so i'll let you talk to him one more
time
so you know it was like okay i love you
everything's gonna be all right he said
okay i love you too and that was the
last conversation i had with him david
died from covet 19 in early april in
quick succession lucy lost more members
of her family her sister-in-law a nephew
and david's elderly mother whom she
cared for
all of a sudden
i was alone
i'd never been alone in that house ever
by myself
with my dog me and my dog
in this house
where everybody that lived here except
me died
of covid by then the pandemic was
completely out of control in a new york
hospital 13 patients died in a single
day but the worst was yet to come
hospitals were overwhelmed morgues ran
out of space for the dead the country
shut down
why did the wealthiest most
technologically advanced country on
earth suffer such a staggering death
toll i think the jury is still out on
exactly what
caused so much death there's a recent
study that came out that
showed that about 40 percent of the
deaths
of the patients who died with covid had
diabetes by the time safe and effective
vaccines became widely available
misinformation and conspiracy theories
were circulating the parallel epidemic
of this information misinformation has
complicated matters tremendously really
unnecessarily former president trump
downplayed the severity of the outbreak
from the beginning the federal
government left it up to each state to
figure out for themselves how to find
medical equipment and protective gear
the ineptness of it was
it was boggling
mind boggling
how did this happen in the united states
of america the virus took advantage of
poverty racial and economic inequities
in american society the covet death
rates for blacks and latinos have been
twice that of whites
how will the pandemic evolve in the
coming years predicting the virus's
behavior is notoriously difficult but
doctors are sure of one thing kovid
isn't finished with us yet its
penetration has been such that it will
be around us for forever it's not going
to go away a million dead
and counting rob reynolds al jazeera los
angeles